SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software engineer at
Google here at KubeCon Seattle.
And I have with me Dan Ciruli.
DAN CIRULI: Nailed it.
Good job, Saad.
SAAD ALI: Thank you.
I've been practicing that.
Dan, you are a product
manager of Istio.
DAN CIRULI: This is correct.
SAAD ALI: And we
have been talking
to a few folks about Istio.
Can you talk a little bit about
why is Istio so important?
Why should someone care,
or why should they use it?
DAN CIRULI: Well, I think
in general people should
be using Istio
because the fact is
people are deploying
applications now
that are complex.
And there's lots of
communication between pods,
between clusters even.
And when there's communication
as part of your application,
it's really important to be
able to understand what's
communicating with what, control
what's communicating with what,
and secure all that.
So applications are
distributed now.
You need a way to
reason about that,
to secure it and
then control it.
SAAD ALI: And Istio provides
a nice way to do that.
It builds on top of
Kubernetes, and you
don't have to have
that logic hardcoded
into every single
application that you write.
And you can make modifications
at a fleet level.
DAN CIRULI: That's right.
Right now typically
people who either
don't secure their
applications or they
spend a lot of developer
time figuring out
how to do authentication
and authorization,
same thing goes for monitoring.
Same thing goes for
traffic control.
And if your developers
are writing, say,
authentication code, they're
not writing business code.
If you're an insurance
company, they're
not writing insurance app code.
And so what we try to do is
just give more out of the box
so developers can spend more
of their time writing services.
SAAD ALI: So that's the classic
separation of concerns design
principle being applied
at a larger scale.
DAN CIRULI: That's
exactly right.
SAAD ALI: Great.
So can you talk
a little bit more
about what the current
functionality is in terms
of the open source product?
DAN CIRULI: Yeah.
So the three main things that
people are getting from Istio
today are observability,
which is just
the ability to understand how
your application is working.
That means gathering
telemetry on every call.
It means gathering logs
on every call and traces
and putting those
in a common place.
In open source, that
might be Prometheus.
Some people are using it to
send all that information
to Datadog.
We have an open adapter that's
sending it to Stackdriver.
The second big thing is control.
When a service needs
a call somewhere else,
where is that service?
How do you find it?
Is there say a canary
rollout going right now?
Istio let's you control that.
And then the last thing
really is security,
automatically putting
MTLS on every single call
so that all of your data
is encrypted in transit
and so that once you have a
strong identity for each call,
you can perform authorization.
There's three big benefits
that they're getting today.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
And what's coming up next
in terms of the open source
side of things?
DAN CIRULI: In terms
of open source,
we've got a big focus on
scalability and performance.
We've got people who are
running in production today.
We also have people
who are not yet
running in production
because they're too big,
people who are running
thousands of services.
Much like Kubernetes
in the early days,
Istio wasn't ready for that.
So we've had a big emphasis on
scalability and performance.
Second big thing we're
working on is multi-cluster.
Lots of people are running
multiple clusters today.
It might be that they're doing
it across different regions.
It might be that they need
for data locality reasons,
and it might be because
they're using different cloud
providers and/or data centers.
But in all those cases,
they need communication
between those clusters,
and so we are working hard
to make it much easier to
simultaneously make calls
from cluster to cluster while
maintaining that observability,
security, and control.
SAAD ALI: Got it.
So definitely a lot more
coming down the pipe.
I understand that GKE offers
Istio as a managed service.
Can you talk a little bit about
that and what GKE adds to it?
DAN CIRULI: So what
we announced today--
yesterday was Istio on GKE.
And what that is it's an
automated installation
and upgrade of the Istio
components into a GKE cluster.
What that means is that
some people have complained
that helm is relatively new.
People don't really like it.
We said, hey, we'll do
the installation for you.
It helps people get started.
More importantly, we do
the upgrade for you, too.
Upgrades are pain.
One of the things
people love about GKE
is that we upgrade
your nodes for you.
We update GKE.
Well, if you're
using Istio and GKE,
we also update the
Istio components.
And so that's a big benefit.
It's just going to make
it easier to get started.
We also are by default
sending all your metrics,
all your logs, and
traces to Stackdriver.
So people can go create really
good service dashboards,
the golden signals
that Istio monitors.
What is the rate of traffic
on each service, what's
the error rate, what
are your latencies
and different percentiles?
Lots of people don't know that.
If you use Istio
on GKE, you're just
going to see that
in Stackdriver.
SAAD ALI: And so what
is your recommendation
for customers who might be
interested in adopting Istio?
How do they get started?
DAN CIRULI: Oh, I think this is
the easiest way to get started.
Turn up a GKE cluster or take
an existing one, install it.
One thing to note is that that
for Istio, some of the things
it does fairly transparently,
if you're just using it
for monitoring, you don't
have to change the way you
write your application at all.
Same thing is true for MTLS.
If you want to get into
more sophisticated features,
if you want to try
doing canary rollouts,
say, you're going to have to
understand the Istio networking
concepts, and you have to
think about those things.
But if what you
really want is just
observability into your services
or just MTLS in your services,
you don't have to
change anything.
Install it and it'll
just start working.
SAAD ALI: That's super cool.
Let's switch gears a little bit.
And we're here at
KubeCon, of course.
This is the largest
KubeCon we've ever had.
I imagine this is not
your first KubeCon.
DAN CIRULI: It is not.
SAAD ALI: Can you
tell us a little bit
about what the
changes that you've
seen over time through with
the various KubeCons you've
attended and the
community at large.
DAN CIRULI: This is
an amazing conference.
I've been to a lot of
conferences in my day.
And the sense of community
here and the energy is bizarre.
It really is.
And I'll tell you,
I've been a vendor.
We're on a show floor right now.
I've been at show floors
where tumbleweeds could
go blowing down the aisle--
I'm not kidding-- because
it's not worth going.
And here there is so much
happening in this space
right now that everywhere you
look there are people having
interesting conversations.
And this isn't something
where all the vendors are just
scrabbling trying to get someone
to come listen to their sales
pitch.
It's where people are
coming here to learn.
The sessions are fantastic.
But everything that's going
on in this space is fantastic.
So, of course, it's
getting bigger.
Everyone's been saying,
oh, it's so much bigger.
Of course.
It's growing exponentially
it seems like.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, we were
talking to Louie earlier today,
and he mentioned that he
hasn't had a chance to attend
any of the talks
because everybody's just
so interested in talking
to him about Istio.
DAN CIRULI: The thing
is that all of the talks
are going to be recorded.
You can watch all that later.
What you can't do is go talk
to her and him and that person
right there later.
And so, yes, I
think a lot of us--
I have been talking to
people nonstop today,
and I'll catch up
on sessions later.
SAAD ALI: That's awesome.
And speaking of sessions,
is there anything
that you're interested
in watching later?
DAN CIRULI: There are a
bunch of Istio sessions
I'm going to watch.
Envoy also-- Istio's
getting a lot of attention.
Part of that is because
we did choose Envoy,
and there is so much
happening in the Envoy space
just on its own.
And I'm certainly going to go
back and catch some of that.
SAAD ALI: Awesome.
And last question, what is
your favorite KubeCon memory?
DAN CIRULI: My favorite
KubeCon memory.
That's a really,
really tough one.
I'm going to have to say
Kelsey Hightower keynotes.
SAAD ALI: Oh, yes.
DAN CIRULI: And it's hard
to pick a particular one
because they're always amazing.
Last year-- here's a
completely non-technical thing.
Kelsey Hightower did his
entrance three times.
He came out, he
did his entrance,
he's like what's happening.
That's not enough.
I'm going to go
back do that again.
And he came out, and, of
course, then the crowd's
really yelling.
He was like that's not enough.
And the third time people
are practically on feet.
It was a very Kelsey
moment, and I loved it.
SAAD ALI: We love Kelsey.
Well, thank you very much, Dan.
And enjoy the rest
of your KubeCon.
DAN CIRULI: Had a blast.
Thanks, Saad.
SAAD ALI: Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]